In this algorithm we will count all of the elements that match a certain
criterion. When you have a picture, we say that the picture is in landscape
orientation if it is wider than it is tall. Most, but not all of these
pictures, of course, contain a landscape. We say that the picture is in
portrait orientation if it is taller, than it is wide. Now let's say we have a
bunch of pictures and we want to count how many of them are in portrait
orientation. That's an example of a counting problem, in general you keep a
counter. You visit each element. If the element is a match for whatever it is
you're looking for you increment the counter. What does it mean to be a match?
Well that depends on the problem. If you have an array of bacteria, we might be
looking for the ones that are beneficial. If you have an array of pictures,
like we have in our example, we happen to want to know the ones that are
portrait. Those are the ones for which the height is greater than the width.
Now that's your job in the next quiz. Complete the program so that it counts,
how many pictures are taller than their way.